so i want to ask about your instagram
page because you're into instagram i i
yes i'd shamefully say i'm into it only
because i've met amazing writers amazing
painters i've met amazing
yeah
if you're disciplined around it it can
be an amazing tool does disciplined mean
like you're not on it all the time
yeah no i'm definitely not on it and
when i'm not looking at you know the
kardashians i'm really utilizing
what i'm not just checking out yeah yeah
yeah wait so do you mind if we go
through something because there's one of
you gave her that underwear that's
amazing
who makes that
how is it only on in the front
that's so weird is it tape
[Applause]
we're gonna go through how do they get
bigger and smaller it's so weird is it a
diet
anyway oh my god wait what's going on
here i'm gonna show you something this
shirt and i want it this is it is
but this is a good look yeah
i think this is a man who has children
this is
this is a man who did the goonies and
never did anything after that
is this your ranch
no that's santa fe new mexico while we
were doing the series that we'll
eventually talk about maybe yes outer
ranch yes we will we will because i'm
actually very into anything supernatural
so wait are you i want to see this one
wait there's another one and this is a
giant babe this is my favorite one wait
for it here we go wait for it keep it
going and how y'all
like
like
i'm actually impressed because i know
i know you got to be cute or whatever um
so wait so no i'm actually impressed
because i've had a sumo wrestler like
that on because it's just who i am and
it was not halloween it was just a
wednesday and and i tried to move in it
and it's hard and you full-on did like
karate moves yeah well because you're
thanos no because you will do anything
for your children that's true anything
for your children so your kid's the
youngest isn't till like the
embarrassing stage my daughter she's
like she's she gets embarrassed of you
know what age did that happen like eight
years she's almost eight she's literally
almost eight yeah yeah i've been through
that though i told you no i know but i'm
like that cutie yeah she thinks you're
real funny now yeah i wonder if i did
that in front of her like that yeah if
it would be if as long as it's not you
it's it's funny i'm 39 years old and i
think it's funny when are you 40 by the
way 40 april 24th happy birthday thank
you
that's great
um so wait then there's this post i want
to show this one too wait here we go um
this is a great
this is actually a good insight to who
you are you see how uncomfortable your
audience is
is this you back in the day is this
someone else this is okay this is the
back story of this so
i had friends backstory i had all these
my whole life needs a back story but i
had friends calling friends going what
happened to him is he okay right
someone get him so this is i made it
seem like it was me this is somebody i
found on instagram
after looking at the kardashians
like yeah what voice and it kind of
looks like a guy you know because they i
don't know the way the picture is or
it's faded out or whatever it's blurred
out it's not a guy so i wrote this whole
thing tried perineum sunning that i've
been hearing about the suggestions do
not do this my pucker hole is crazy burn
i was going to spend the day shopping
with my family and instead i'm icing and
using aloe and burn creams instead of
the severity of the paint so that so but
then i found out that that's a woman who
does that and i'm happy for her
and that she gave me the ammunition to
make it my own yeah she gave you art
she gave you art
in order to come in to your talk show
something to talk who needs to talk
about outer rings
my question for that in life is why does
that need to be tan
what are you what are you doing or is
the vitamin d that important there like
i don't understand but you can equally
turn that around and say why does it
need to be bleached exactly and why
would somebody do that i did i did it
last week and it does not oh oh i
don't knock it until you've tried it at
least twice maybe i don't know
once it's like just for the experience
twice is like i don't know i might be in
or not
i did wax i'm
gonna i'm going to move on that can be
painful i like it and you might scream
my name apparently
[Music]
you